I want to address what you were saying
about you know would I prove I'm wrong
if I could I suppose what happened
differently for us it was that vitriolic
if it was that vitriolic yeah I didn't
granted did it daily wire added
themselves and they said it was because
people assumed it was them uh
after I had a conversation my
determination uh conversating with the
daily wire my determination was they do
business in a way that I don't agree
with but I like that they're doing
things that have a cultural impact in
the positive thus I'm gonna build my
thing the way I think it's supposed to
be let them make the things they make
with the people who agree with being a
part of that and hopefully even if
they're not 100 in the right direction
if it's one percent producing cultural
net positive I'll just have to be the
force that pushes it what if it's 80 net
negative that's your view right I I
don't I I think well again I agree the
people who the investors in our case
right there's there are no other
investors right I don't know 100 of my
company we've entered into licensing
agreements where people have temporary
ability to monetize the subscribers and
the content they're in right we still
have all the content and when we uh when
we left the blaze we still have that
because there was a period of time the
issue there is what we're talking about
is penalizing people on behalf of big
Tech was that your impression because
that's not the impression that's given
and you know what there are a lot of
things that that you can get and I
really want this to be done just pledge
that we won't penalize people on behalf
of big Tech we can talk about it hey
there are ways to do it with with Rumble
I know you've talked about a
decentralized solution to people
subscribing right and I think yeah
there's good with that there are also
issues because people have so many
different places where they have to pay
right now and they kind of want to get
one portal hopefully there's a way to
figure that out here's what you do as
far as a contract if it's someone is
coming in this entire production house
I've been having contracts negotiated
you know you said you were in Sag uh
2000 so I I wasn't since I was 12 years
old
uh and had agents negotiating contracts
and term sheets I know what a term sheet
looks like every time we do a live show
by the way I'll be in Louisville
Kentucky February 10th I think we're
adding a show on Thursday you can go buy
tickets on the website every time I do a
live show there's a term sheet and the
term sheet is this is what happens with
live shows okay there's a minimum
guarantee yeah and the minimum guarantee
is no matter five people show up if it's
you know your dad and your aunt Tilly we
pay this and there's a percentage of the
gate and if you want more if you're
willing to bet on yourself right you say
lower that guarantee and take a higher
portion of the gate I go in and say
don't give me a guarantee and I'll just
take the gate and they sell their drinks
right they end up making more money
we're giving them less risk what you do
is Luke to answer your question you can
present it if it's a production company
where you want them to incur all of the
risk all of the costs okay you do a REV
split whether it's upside for both sides
or some people want security right we
have 1099s who work at the company we
have employees some people want security
and so they become salaried and they get
health insurance they get a 401k you can
ride two options
you can do a REV split or you can do an
employee agreement for people who want
to do that in this case they want to do
employee type constraints and again none
of this matters as far as I can't be
clear enough I said take me off the
table here the issue is entirely the
enforcement of bit of punitive practices
through mandate at the most powerful
company but you can do it those ways and
there are there are a million ways to
skin a cat you can make that work and
that's the way that it's done we both
know in the liberal Cesspool that is
Hollywood where everyone is out trying
to screw somebody they still know that
you can't do that they still know that
that's one the decision to remain
monetized rests with the Creator and
always stays there it's not a part of
the model because so you're 51 yes
that's fine unless we fast forward five
years five years from now daily wire is
Undisputed number one five million
subscribers and big Tech turns the
switch
would it be better to course correct a
little bit now with a little bit of pain
or would it be better to wait until it's
too late it's better to do it now
because Microsoft could buy daily wire
tomorrow it's very dangerous to
consolidate it's a really good point or
BlackRock BlackRock Rumble tomorrow
Rumble is not safe it's it's a private
company that's all centralized company
and here's the one thing that I like
about because look Rumble tweeted out
like hey we offer these non-restrictive
contracts I think was it France right
rumble's a public company think of the
balls it takes for I think it was the
government of France that you have to
start changing content and they said
right when you're a public company and
you tell an entire government fine
that's that's the kind of balls that
people are expecting and these people
and by the way the guy who runs is a
Canadian the CEO he's not he's not even
I don't think he's super conservative he
just sees the writing on the wall why
did those people get it why because he's
been under the I would say tyranny now
when you see someone like Trudeau just
because he does blackface and he can't
throw a jab doesn't mean he's not a
tyrant right people have lived into that
tyranny they go we can't let that happen
here so Rumble gets it they tell France
to go fornicate themselves with a wire
brush but the people who who take money
from harder conservative Americans who
are wondering how they can fight back
how they can have a voice don't see it
do they not see it or is it the business
model right you can't that's what I'm
wondering did you feel like your buddy
and then what I mean your buddy like
Jeremy you and Jeremy are transition or
friends or whatever but that he
lowballed he knows your value when you
low balls you and you're like dude if
you're gonna do that to me I'm taking
I'm going scorched Earth
it wasn't the low ball it wasn't the
Lobo it was it was the hey look prompt
look let's just sit down and talk about
how you can do this without mandating
through punitive practices against not
some according to him in his video
oh conservative content creators let's
find a different way because there's no
future in this there's a lot of there's
a lot there that's permissible right in
business money I get it yeah lowball
sure
um and and you know that everyone knows
that um but what's really hard to deal
with is there was a period like I talked
about with jail note where I was super
depressed
um felt kind of hopeless because this
has been a long time in the making and
you you knock on one door and you have
people you think are on your side you
know no wait this is how it works and
then you because you don't see behind
you know the uh the curtain you hear
that we're fighting back against big
Tech and you see this offer and you go
oh there's no there's no future here and
the response to this is not right has
always been money money money money I
can't stress it enough so it's not about
the money so what is the future in your
mind then what what needs to be done
what first needs to be done is people to
mean what they say and if you are taking
money from conservatives out there under
the guys that you're fighting big Tech
start fighting big Tech start
with that okay I don't know about the
and I know that when I say this by the
way they're going to send they're gonna
be four or five Hatchet men coming from
the daily I understand that by the way
have you seen anyone else in these
videos is the first time Gerald's been
here because I'm like look you handle
the finances more than I do it's me it's
two on one it's three on one it's four
on one and gee golly we thought we were
friends and you know what I'm not going
to call anyone a I still I mean
what I said Andrew Clay was one of my
all-time favorite people I think Jordan
Peterson is unbelievable I go to the
wall for that guy think Ben Shapiro is
brilliant never met Candace Owens um
Michael Knowles my experience with him I
don't know him as well I really like him
I like a lot of these people good singer
is he a good singer well he has that
voice I mean Andrew Cleveland he told me
that voice since he was like six words
like well teach your own parent teacher
appreciation day I'll give you an apple
and they're like this is how you talk
um and it's it's genuine it's genuine
send it here's the thing keep doing it
if that's what they want
I'm not going to at a certain point my
tolerance will run out so send four send
five certain point don't send anyone you
expect back in one piece but what will
you make right you talked in the
beginning something you're saying
something about
um it's hard for everyone to just pay
all across the board randomly to
different people
like if you want to support a Creator
you're on one website you're on another
website yes yeah yeah so so how would
you it's a subscription fatigue right
you have the same with like Netflix and
Hulu so can I answer your question with
a question to um to crash test dummies
here that doesn't offend you right
it does look like one oh my god
there you go yeah I love it there's
National what's your question my
question for him is because he said like
this might be a solution you have this
idea or or you're creating an actual
product I don't know all of it yeah but
decentralized way to subscribe to people
because and also people who create get
to keep their subscribers by the way
this isn't daily wire it is industry
standard in the conservative sphere you
don't get to know how many subscribers
you have you don't get to take them with
you which only hurts people who are
paying if you end up leaving you know if
you end up not being with a network
that's industry standard not daily wire
again stop bitcon was not just about
daily wire you don't even know you don't
even get to reach them that is the
standard not just there and you
mentioned something before the show and
I'm a little ignorant as to what it is
forgive me you said it's like this
decentralized ability for people to sort
of an anti-patreon is what I think oh
yeah it is just basically doing what
patreon does but without a patreon
middleman so it'd be a piece a software
packet that you download install on your
computer and then you can start
uploading videos through the software
packet to rumble as a server or YouTube
as a server okay unlisted the videos and
then people would go to your website
where you have a front end hosted with
this packet and they can subscribe 10
bucks a month that they can see on your
website the unlisted videos from the
other sites it's pretty rudimentary it's
what Tim's using a system like that he's
not using it that doesn't sound
rudimentary at all so that was like chip
Douglas with a remote controls like his
basic cable stuff incredibly complicated
here's to pull off the idea right now is
that you're an independent Creator yeah
you go to patreon you go to locals yeah
you go to someone else's company you
sign up there's the infrastructure you
give them 10 right I've done the math 10
is steep but they're trying to run a
business have employees so I get it sure
so we we were talking about this a long
time ago make the software you get your
own server space your cost you get your
own domain your cost you install that
software for free open source and boom
instantly your website is a a clone of a
subscription service website with an
easy to use backend for you that
networks with anyone else who uses it
you can also Blacklist certain sites
from your site if you're like I don't
want my site to recommend this you know
Skittles and rainbows.com
you know very nasty stuff right there so
but or or it's just you let the
algorithm uh recommend whatever the
recommend like similar words and phrases
so what this does is if I go to your
website and you want to be included in
the network people will see and this
could be bad for business some people
might want to do it they will see like
recommended Tim cast IRL episode with
Stephen Crowder and be like oh I'd like
to watch that show too creating uh it's
so YouTube's one of the powerful things
about YouTube is that it recommends
shows after shows yeah and that
recommendations on my shows it's Seth
Meyers
way better than Seth Meyers is good this
is the point it used to be legitimate it
used to be that if you watched Crowder
you get recommended similar shows or
more Crowder now they're driving
everyone away right and so they're
taking away the natural uh networking
marketing value so our idea was create
it decentralized no one gets a cut of
your money that's your business you got
to spend money on your bandwidth that's
your business
but it's free open source and it rips it
rips away from the centralization and
creates so I really like that now here's
the one thing too that Gerald kind of
knows is
um it's always been true north to me is
the viewer right it's a person watching
is how do they get the most value for
their money
and there are so many places to
subscribe right now it's too fragmented
yes and I under but I also understand
the danger of a centralized power right
but if there would be a way for kind of
like you were talking about with maker
for there to be an alliance where maybe
there's some kind of a price break or
discount if you get to subscribe to
these other creators right so that you
don't have to do six dollars on a
patreon here five dollars you know on
locals here and by the way nothing wrong
with it I'm just saying people feel like
there's this payment fatigue the
subscription fatigue if we want to fight
the Left Right think about just what
they call the stream with Batista he's
in this like canoe uh talking about like
Disney ESPN and uh what is it Disney and
Hulu right that's a value added and I
think this is what was so disheartening
is was really hoping that we could do
that and the conservative movement where
people can kind of get access to a
portal and support the people that they
want to uh I don't know that it's
possible
um but if there would be some way for
the view because for the viewer what's
ideal is to be able to get access to
more people that they want rather than
having it because the price adds up
right now it's hard it's like 10 bucks
for Tim 10 bucks for you with this Tech
that I'm building we haven't had the
multi subscription system set up but you
could do something where it's like 10
for him 10 for you or 18 for both of you
then you each get nine you'll eventually
have to take some sort of lost discount
if you're going to run a packet
otherwise it would just be right it's
hard to figure out that right yeah it is
it's tough to figure it out
um but there are ways to do it obviously
people on the left have done it some
degree
um the worst thing that I will say the
thing that really is is YouTube is it
YouTube red or YouTube premium what are
they premium yeah I tell you what though
you know what sucks about it that's
actually a really good deal you get
YouTube music which replaces Spotify you
get YouTube TV which replaces cable and
sling and you get HBO Max you're like
but they're subsidized yes yes they are
obsessed but guess what
so are these companies on the right all
right but they're subsidizing it in a
way that is not foundationally sound for
a move forward let me tell you something
that really I feel like this should
require hallucinogens I'm so happy too
if you're interested
let me let me let me tell you guys
something that that is kind of crazy to
me
and people don't believe
there are no investors in timcast there
are only there's only me as the
principal of the entire company Soul
owner sole board member president CEO
Treasurer chairman et cetera et cetera
et cetera their staff you know I have a
CEO we have we've got people who work
here but I own literally all of it
control all of it with no outside
investment it's literally just I started
making you're not even Jewish yeah I'm
I'm uh I'm just saying to the
anti-semites
we're not talking about no one talking
about isn't even Jewish that's a point I
make all the time there are people who
have been successful in media who aren't
I don't know why they have that
conspiracy belief but my it was shocking
for me to find out that these these big
alternatives
only exist because some powerful
industrialist or billionaire decided I'm
going to spend money but that that money
comes with their influence now the only
issue I have with that is that we don't
know what their influence is and you oh
if right if you come to timcast.com you
know the whole influence in driving
force behind this is literally just me
if you're a customer here as a member or
whatever you're supporting us it is
literally me in charge of everything but
a lot of these other companies you don't
know who who's behind the scenes putting
money in and saying hey guys I want to
see this
I understand how businesses work I
understand investment works but you
won't know and if you knew it's ball
retractingly terrifying I mean that
there's some information again that
you're not going to open third prize
it's probably going to be coming out in
the next six months year that will shock
people start all people I can tell you
that but would have to provide receipts
and would that be a betrayal that's the
issue right I've given you a lot of
information that you can publicly audit
and I think that's important I'm not
going to pull people in like I said Gary
said you can use it I can't show you the
three four five other instances just in
the last two years where that's happened
it is absolutely terrifying but what was
the crazy idea you were saying I thought
you were like I thought you were gonna
like I thought you just came up with a
business plan or something oh it's it's
just I was saying it's crazy to me
that's not so crazy that's totally
reasonable I guess that's why I'm
throwing no no no no what's crazy to me
is that we've gone to the point we have
without that when it seems when
seemingly no one else does it's really
but here's what I want to say Stephen
really I'm looking I'm looking at I
don't think it's really to have the
website rolling with Subs oh no
from people who like run these sort of
credit card processing these platforms
are offering to give us better rates as
well so there are a lot of people who've
come forward uh like I said I mean daily
it's not about daily wire wasn't even
the highest offer just but here's what I
want to say yeah I'm going to say this
right in in front of every every single
person I think you're going to make a
hundred million dollars a year yeah I
think you're absolutely insane I think I
I think I'm right but I would never
demand that just to be clear setting
from yeah did I tell you my new job yes
for crying out loud I you're trying to
you're trying to get my heart attack I I
I've seen your numbers
I know look we've got 175 000 people
watching on a show that normally gets 40
40 to 45 000. 130 000 live viewers
tripling quadrupling quadrupling the
live viewership we get because you came
to talk about something that's important
to you you have people who are not only
fans of your content who are entertained
by it but also believe in you looking at
your mug club numbers
I think you launched this thing you
maybe maybe not look it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna snowball rolling down a
hill I think you launched this thing and
you're making three to five million per
month right off the get-go by the way
you mean the old production company
whole production company which your
staff in their budgets I'm gonna fork in
the road
you're gonna get a lot of people to sign
up I could walk away and I understand
this isn't lost on me the only way
people will 100 believe what I say and
that there's no ulterior motive which is
what I try to do in the negotiations
like take me off the table this is why
this is a sticking point is if I walk
away from this forever
is if I never monetize again and I just
go back off into the sunset just you
know do stand up maybe do a once a week
show something like that so I can
continue selling out the the venues and
I could do that and general knows that I
strongly consider that at one point
and I think he was the one if I'm not
saying you said like yeah but then if
you do that then this will just all blow
over in two months and it'll be the same
problem so I do I get I get the question
of authenticity again but I would ask
you if this is the easy decision if this
is the easy route to make uh route to
take could have just taken the money
shut up could have gone off and I don't
think it's 100 million I think you're
absolutely insane no I'm not I think I
think he slipped you nope nope now look
we know what the daily wires subscriber
numbers they have a what a million
paying subscribers they it's it's
between seven and thirteen dollars per
month to be a member there we they've
talked about their yearly Revenue
thirteen dollars okay for their video
content I believe it's 13. they run some
promos and stuff like that but yeah yeah
different teams and it's like you know
look I think let's Luke wants to talk
about the IRS
and I've seen Maxwell's candle I'm I'm
saying for one the easy route for you
would have absolutely been sign the deal
take the money and shut up let everyone
else worry about all the problems and go
sit on the beach of the coconut and just
do the bare minimum yeah but I think if
you go the hard way which running a
company especially with I think the size
of memberships you're gonna have is
going to be
very difficult and time consuming but
just you know make Gerald do all the
harm
if we continue down this route then
there's got to be other people right we
have to have other shows on there I
could have again just gone off and done
it and just kept my club but I said like
look either I'm gonna leave at this
point or we can't just complain and
we have to do it better and that's
kind of where we are and by the way we
still haven't decided what it is that
we're going it's it's a tough decision
to make I own 100 of mug Club always
have uh we did the mug clever so we now
know how many people are out there you
know we were really clear we're like do
not go to muggler Forever unless you are
currently in my club we're going to sign
up to be double capture double opt-in
called the list so we know like don't go
and is it a newsletter no there you go
nothing any updates only when and where
and if mug Club returns and there's a
little bit of a Young Frankenstein oval
team nothing let me ask you let me yeah
do you think that
when you you are going to launch
something independent it's going to be
mug Club but then you're going to add on
shows do you think you'll be bigger than
the daily wire
uh I don't care no no real question
based on your memberships uh based on
the amount of views you get do you think
you will be bigger than I'm not saying
it says it would it would if if I
decided that I uh let me answer it this
way I've wanted to be done with this by
the time I'm 40 as far as hosting the
show on air the last thing you want to
do is overstay your welcome and then
move to a you know um I wouldn't say
like necessarily uh like a harvey
weinsteiner like a Bruckheimer but more
like a Suge Knight you know how old are
you though uh 35 okay so
um and I want to be able to pass that
toward when's your birthday July July
okay yeah so um I want to be able to
pass that torch right now there is no
ability to because you now realize
there's no ability for people to come up
and do
it would be really hard for you to do
what you do now today you know that
right yeah and harder and harder and
it'd be harder it'd be impossible for
someone to do what I do I don't want to
pull the ladder up behind me so I want
to be able to move into a production
role but really what motivates me is
being able to pass that mantle and make
a difference I guarantee you if we were
to do it it'd be within Striking
Distance of the big boys
um which I'd be fine with but as long as
we do something that we believe in and I
I promise we will never demand people's
YouTube monetization We will never
punish them if they are not uh and it
has to be something fair and it has to
be us not shortchanging the investor
meaning the people mug Club it's
entirely independent paying us for to
fight for what they believe whatever
those numbers are I'd accept them I'll
tell you my my prediction which who
knows could be worthless
Mr Thomas hit me you you launch uh
Subscription Service independent mug
Club you get 300 000 hard sign ups at 10
or more per month I mean it was 10 bucks
a month for for a lot of people it's
going up because of inflation because
you know people need raises and things
like that but let's say you did 10 bucks
a month you're looking at like 3 million
in memberships with no ad reads at all
let's say you do programmatic reads and
the podcast version meaning you Steven
never read a single ad then you're
looking at another based on your traffic
I'd estimate another two to five million
dollars per uh per year not per month so
right off the bat you're looking at 40
million dollars per year then here's
what happens Stephen Crowder then offers
big players
really good contracts no BS no fees none
of that out the gate it's a legitimately
good contract that gives your business a
small cut but gives them the Lion's
Share for the work they produce they're
going to say oh I'm signing with with
mug club that the terms were incredible
I mean Crowder's gonna make money off
the deal the company is going to grow
the giraffes with the hats that's right
I'm getting a lot of money then what's
going to happen is it's going to make it
very difficult for the big con these
other big conservative companies to sign
these deals when a young Trader says I
appreciate the offer it's tempting but
Crowders offered me twice the money with
no with no setbacks yeah I would really
really like it real genuinely and Gerald
knows this if there's someone else in
the space who handles that because
because I'm not a business guy
I'm not a business guy I'm a guy who out
punted his coverage right you can go
back and watch with a blue bed sheet who
is doing stand-up comedy and acting and
then had kind of put had my back up
against the wall right I would really
like it if there was someone else who
already has the money who already has
that ability to do it if they can't okay
I'll carry that torch but there well I
don't know maybe there's someone out
there are there enough good men and
enough people left because that's that's
not the best use of my time like it
takes a lot of time to do a Good Will
Hunting do you have any idea how hard it
is to make Schindler's List funny when
you're doing a parody you know what I
mean uh like it's a lot of work that's
where my time is better and that's where
the time by the way of all the creators
is best spent yeah but instead they're
being forced to make this decision you
know you're a creative type you want to
deal with numbers and back-end business
it's exhausting yeah I have to do it I
know I don't want to do it I have to so
I'm building this technology but like
boring that's what Jeremy boring why you
have to do it why because we need a new
subscription service for creators it
shouldn't fall upon you though I have
two questions yeah let's do it exactly
exactly if not you if not me who if not
now when that's this let me shout out to
Phillip Fisher the guy building this
stuff pure genius I'll introduce you to
him soon and I will say and I will say
to everybody listening it's you it will
only ever be you when you see a burning
building you think who's gonna call all
this in no no no one's going to call it
it's gonna be you right I once watched
uh when I was 16 years old I saw an old
lady at a bus stop flip over land on her
back and I paused and said I have no
idea what to do what is happening I look
around and I'm like I gotta figure this
one out and I ran full speed into a
building and just screamed call 9-1-1 on
ladies hurt there's nobody else you
could you can't sit back and just cross
your fingers and hope someone else will
take care of the problem right yeah you
got to be the hero of your own story I
just wanted to ask I actually feel
terrible I just wanted to ask two quick
questions for you guys one would you
guys would you guys be open to doing
like competitions or contests for new
talent and a lot of people are asking
about not gay Jared in the in the
comment section can you guys clear up
what's happening in that situation some
people are saying that there's an NDA uh
yeah well that's the thing I think
Candace brought up right again yeah
there's a difference between roping in
third parties versus single party
consent I think he tweeted out what
happened where he left right not gay
Jared he tweeted out that he left it was
his own decision
um we did a whole send-off with him in a
video montage you know this works with
like conspiracies and sometimes look
there's a also a middle ground where
there's for example like what is the
email by the way if people are talking
about shows I think it's creators yeah
creators so that's actually not a bad
idea contest if we do you know but the
reason I didn't want to do it is because
I didn't want to think that's like hey
this is why we're doing this right now
um but we do have a place where people
can reach out the challenge is like
there's completely controlling contracts
right that own your name image likeness
and your platforms that you've already
built in perpetuity okay that's an
extreme example that's big con then you
have people who are like hey I have no
experience I've never done a show but I
really think I could do it well if you
give me money that's a situation where
you'd be incurring all the risk there is
a middle ground and I think what needs
to happen
is if we I'm not going to be in the
business of just creating shows from the
ground up but there are people out there
who say hey look I have a channel that's
doing relatively well I keep hitting the
ceiling that is YouTube saying we need
to play this kind of ball I'm suffering
from the advertising rate to the
sponsorship rates dropping across the
board and I can just be you know the
gasoline on that fire to back them up
really why would you sign with a network
if you're if they're not if they don't
have your back that's the only reason to
otherwise be independent right what is
the upside at that point that's all we
want to be and whatever subscribers you
generate you keep that's the only way I
would be able to do it it's really
publicity these big networks get get
their faces seen But if you can do it
without that but is there is there an
ADA NDA that's what people are asking is
there any is to everyone just like uh
here right to send a waiver when I can
yeah you come into our studio because I
mean standard business practice Yeah you
can you can't come and so you can't come
in and tell people where the studio is
yes
of course yeah if only for location it
would be worth it because he walks
around the pants half the time we have
ndas
um
because we work on projects and in order
it's really really complicated one of
the simplest reasons is like we don't
want you leaking information about us
location is a good and obvious thing but
also projects we're working on cost a
lot of money to preliminary research if
someone then says
goes to a competitor or any other Media
company says here is what you know Tim
Cass is working on all their stuff it
just completely destroys the entire
attempt it makes a project yeah things
like that of course and you have people
stealing you know creative content right
I mean that happens anyway this is the
most common thing that happens right the
big boys they go oh that really works
hey let's do exactly that put 25 million
dollars behind it just to promote it now
it's ours
perpetuity Clauses really quick before
we go to super chats because you brought
them up a couple times yeah yeah dog
nasty and need to be removed immediately
from Modern entertainment contracts
Because deep fakes they're going to be
able to take someone's perpetuity face
deep fake it to make it look real and
have it say stuff that the person
doesn't agree with by the time I'm dead
and you're going to my Mausoleum I'm
going to be Hawking Black Rifle
coffee
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time